die idee mich hassen sagen immer die
wahrheit
sowas wie die wahrheit gibt es nicht
jeder hat seine eigene macht dadurch das
leben auf einer wahren begebenheit
beruht ein bisschen heikel krieg die
liste der regisseur macht von anfang an
klar dass es hier um versionen krieg ich
war die beste eiskunstläuferin der welt
amerika wir wollen jemanden den sie
lieben können aber sie wollen auch
jemanden den sie hassen kann ich mein
ich bete sich was winfried vertreten die
kniescheibe seiner freundin echt jetzt
mir tut der freundin so was an und aus
dieser widersprüchlichkeit generiert
kollektive spd allerdings eine ganz
interessante soziale erzählung man
erfährt viel über das weiße amerika von
dem viele spielen amerika bis heute
gerne hätten dass es nach wie vor das
einzig relevante amerika ist ein
bisschen ist es auch dass trump amerika
und aus dieser welt gewissermaßen passt
von ja nicht so richtig in das milieu
des eiskunstlaufs sollten sie sich einen
anderen sport suchen jetzt mein arsch im
film erhielten ist das ein film vor
allem zwei schauspielerinnen war der
robbie hat sich mit großem engagement
diese rolle beworben
sie spielt auch eine sehr beantworte
alle rolle denn anne harding durchläuft
viele verschiedene stadien und alles das
bringt mal überhaupt sehr sehr gut auf
die leinwand
ihr gegenüber steht als ihre mutter war
eine schauspielerin die auch mit einem
oscar für diese nebenrolle ausgezeichnet
wurde
wenn man so möchte das negative herz des
films eine ungeheuerliche frau das wird
allerdings abgefedert durch ihre dann
doch verhalten komme die amtliche
darstellung aber er ist ein monster
wenn das baby ein film wie er in
hollywood heute schon fast eine ausnahme
geworden ist mit sehr viel witz im
detail mit einer sehr sehr guten tonlage
der die figuren denunziert werden
so kann man als fazit von einem wirklich
gelungenen amerikanischen mainstream
film sprechen für den es viele gründe
gibt ins kino zu gehen
hör auf damit